[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans ce sens public votre
émission de débat et de reportage sur
Public Sénat toute la chaîne toute la
rédaction qui est évidemment mobilisé
dispositif spécial pour suivre jusqu'à
dimanche soir l'examen de la réforme des
retraites et justement le président du
Sénat Gérard larchie sera notre invité
dans une minute pourquoi cette réforme
lui semble indispensable comment les
sénateurs veulent-ils enrichir la loi
sur les carrières longues la retraite
des maires de famille fera t-il tout ce
qui est en son pouvoir pour que le texte
soit débattu jusqu'au bout et voter
dimanche que répond-il aux accusations
de partialité de certains sénateurs de
l'opposition et puis cette réforme
peut-elle rabattre les cartes des
alliances entre groupes politiques d'ici
à la fin du quinquennat vous le voyez
beaucoup de questions à venir dans cette
émission et puis juste après avec nos
experts c'est l'avenir du mouvement
social que l'on va décortiquer l'Inter
syndical voulait mettre la France à
l'arrêt
c'était une formule en tout cas la
française elle est largement ralentie et
ça va continuer et je vous l'ai dit ça
ne peut que s'amplifier si on continue à
avoir autant d'indifférence autant de
mépris du côté du pouvoir les limites du
blocage à l'heure du télétravail et de
l'inflation les risques d'une
radicalisation qui échapperait au
syndicat les stratégies politiques après
la mobilisation record de mardi on va
balayer l'ensemble de l'actualité
retraite avec nos experts dans notre
second débat pendant plus d'une heure
mais d'abord donc l'examen de la réforme
qui avance l'article 8 sur les carrières
longues au menu des sénateurs cet
après-midi Samia de chien
chaque nouvelle journée de débat fait
monter un peu plus l'attention adopter
la nuit dernière c'est d'abord l'article
7 qui a enflammé les débats sur la
réforme des retraites au Sénat celui qui
prévoit de repousser l'âge légal de
départ à 64 ans la gauche a déposé plus
de 1200 amendements sur l'article la
droite sans patiente Criel obstruction
vous êtes en train de vous mélangez
nous
accepte que vous mélanges
la majorité sénatoriale de droite et du
centre finit par mettre sa menace à
exécution elle utilise à plusieurs
reprises l'article 38 du Règlement du
Sénat pour limiter les prises de parole
dans l'hémicycle la gauche explose
honte à vous
vous êtes laissés bâillonner par le 47,1
de la Constitution et le gouvernement et
vous voulez maintenant bayonner votre
position c'est un scandale le rythme
s'accélère et la majorité sénatoriale
parvient enfin à voter le report de
l'âge légal à la retraite à 64 ans mais
dès lors les échanges sont venus la
gauche qui n'a pas dit son dernier mot
multiplie les interventions pour
dénoncer une censure du débat c'est pas
la présidence qui parle c'est la
présidence de la droite on dirait mais
bon je reprends la parole jamais vous
pourrez dire ça jamais
vous essayez de nous bâillonner de nous
intimider de plus plusieurs depuis hier
mais vous ne vous ne priverez pas les
français du débat les deux camps
s'échappent dans un affrontement brûlant
sur la forme mais aussi sur le fond
quand les discussions reprennent sur la
majoration de la retraite des femmes
ayant eu un enfant proposé par la droite
de vision de la famille s'affrontent et
nous avons le projet de faire évoluer la
famille pour qu'elle soit moins
concentrée sur l'idée que la fille
que l'air des enfants et pour s'en
occuper on devrait simplement dire que
la famille pour nous est une valeur
parce que c'est le respect de la parole
donnée de la parole donnée à son con de
créer un nom la parole au final la
majorité de droite et du centre parvient
petit à petit à faire voter ses
propositions pour réécrire le projet de
réforme des retraites mais la bataille
menée par la gauche n'est pas pour
autant sans effet lui c'est netteurs qui
ont approuvé hier le report de l'âge de
départ à la retraite à 64 ans sont
revenus sur leur vote
bonsoir Gérard Larcher bonsoir bienvenue
merci de nous avoir accordé cette
interview plein cœur de de l'examen de
la réforme des retraites ici au Sénat je
suis avec la journée politique Mathilde
Sirault éditeur Elise pour son physique
transformative ensemble on va vous
interviewer pendant 25 minutes beaucoup
de questions évidemment sur le contenu
de la réforme on viendra aussi sur les
critiques exprimées par certains
sénateurs voilà sur la gestion du
calendrier on nous bâillonne dit
certains d'entre eux vous aurez
l'occasion de répondre mais d'abord cet
article 7 qui est certainement pour la
majorité de gens qui nous regardent le
plus le plus symbolique qui repousse
l'âge légal à 64 ans
c'est cohérent pour le Sénat qui votent
cette mesure depuis plusieurs années
mais elle est rejetée par plus des deux
tiers des Français pourquoi vous
l'imposer il est pas question de
l'imposer nous pensons que il nous faut
sauvegarder un des piliers de notre
modèle social qui s'appelle le système
de retraite par répartition il y a pas
d'autre choix et parce que nous
entendons en permanence parler du
Conseil nation de la résistance
pardonnez-moi le gaulliste que je suis
pense que le système par répartition il
faut le préserver il y a des réalités
quand il y avait quatre actifs pour un
retraité Vous étions dans la décennie 60
70 et pas de problème d'équilibre
aujourd'hui nous avons
1,7 actif pour un retraité si nous ne
prenons pas en compte l'augmentation de
l'espérance de vie ces réalités là nous
aurons un système qui sera plus un
système de solidarité intergénérationnel
et c'est de la responsabilité d'un
politique d'avoir de la cohérence mais
aussi parfois du courage la cohérence
depuis quatre ans la majorité
sénatoriale dans le cas du PLFSS
pose le principe de cette réforme et en
fait ce qui a été voté hier c'est pas le
texte du Gouvernement au fond l'article
7 c'est la réforme que le Sénat propose
chaque mois de novembre ça a été négocié
avec le avec le gouvernement avec
Elisabeth borne voir avec Emmanuel
Macron le fait de finalement que le
gouvernement rentre dans les pas de la
réforme sénatoriale non c'est plutôt le
gouvernement qui avait imaginé d'abord
le faire dans le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et
nous savons simplement dit en tous les
cas puisque j'en ai parlé avec le
président de la République que nous nous
étions prêts dans le cadre et dans
l'esprit de ce que nous proposions
depuis quatre ans avec naturellement des
prises en compte de choses qui sont tout
à fait essentielles c'est d'ailleurs le
débat que nous avons eu
maintenant deux jours sur la question
des seniors la question de le taux
d'emploi des seniors nous sommes dans un
des pays création
c'est un vrai sujet quand j'étais
ministre du Travail c'était déjà un
sujet on utilisait l'âge après 50 ans
les entreprises la plupart d'entre elles
d'investissaient plus dans la formation
permanente des seniors et nous avons un
taux d'emploi du seniors comparé je
recevais le président du Parlement
finlandais il y a deux semaines comparé
à la situation de la Finlande de -10
points donc les Seigneur
il fallait pas la faire avant de poser
la question des retraites éventuellement
de repousser la Liga parce que tout est
lié oui mais bon tout est lié il y avait
d'abord l'emploi je pense qu'on doit au
pays la vérité la cohérence la question
de la pénibilité les poser
la question des carrières hachées des
femmes avec le dossier bien sûr que nous
allons y revenir dans les deux jours qui
viennent la question aussi parce qu'on a
beaucoup parlé des carrières longues et
il y a une étude de l'Institut des
politiques publiques qui démontre en
fait ce qui sont en fin de carrière
entre guillemets les plus abîmés c'est
pas toujours ceux qui ont eu des
carrières longues ce sont des gens qui
ont eu des carrières hachées qui ont
connu des formes de maladies de
pénibilité et pour lequel nous allons
proposer le Sénat que pour certains
d'entre eux puissent partir à la
retraite au contraire plus tôt
de vérité cette réforme elle vise avant
tout voilà c'est un équilibre budgétaire
qu'il faut trouver pour le pour le
système des retraites voilà pour le pour
le préserver pour le maintenir ce matin
ou dans le maire a fait le décompte les
amendements sénatoriaux coûtent à date
450 millions d'euros est-ce qu'on ne va
pas rater cet objectif de malgré tout
faire des économies
d'abord de préserver un de solidarité
intergénérationnelle il s'agit aussi
donné à la perspective de carrière après
50 ans des perspectives qui permettent
de jouer en gros encore pleinement dans
la vie économique et dans la vie sociale
du pays il s'agit d'apporter des
réponses à la pénibilité et pas au
travers d'un index qu'est-ce que vous
répondez au ministre de l'économie
d'une politique sociale qu'il faut
assumer encore faut-il ne pas dégrader
naturellement mais nous savons pris nos
responsabilités c'était inscrit dans les
projets que présentait le Sénat mais
c'est aussi pour rassurer les marchés
financiers l'Union européenne que cette
réforme se fait
rassurer faire comme si
l'Union européenne pardonnez-moi il
suffira pas de la réforme
3000 3000 milliards de dettes nous avons
un déficit du commerce extérieur de plus
de 160 milliards
qu'il faut conduire mais c'est quand
même un message qu'on envoie aussi
peut-être
mais qu'il ne suffira pas voilà pourquoi
politiquement je ne partage pas un
certain nombre de choix de la majorité
relative et du gouvernement si nous les
attaquons pas à la maîtrise des dépenses
publiques si nous ne mettons place en
place une autre organisation de la
gouvernance de ce pays je pense à la
décentralisation je pense la
déconcentration et bien nous ne
résoudrons pas un certain nombre
d'équations qui sont assez terribles au
plan financier à un moment où
l'inflation voyez les chiffres de
l'inflation
est élevé un moment où les taux
d'intérêt ont beaucoup remonté vous
voyez bien que le coût de la dette je
rappelle que nous allons emprunter cette
année pour faire face plus de 270
milliards d'euros il reste une douzaine
d'articles à examiner est-ce que la loi
sera votée dimanche soir écoutez
le Parlement s'est fait pour débattre
délibérer et ensuite s'exprimer par un
vote pour ou contre le rôle d'un
président d'une assemblée le rôle du
président du Sénat c'est de faire que le
Sénat puisse examiner
l'ensemble du texte nous nous sommes
donné beaucoup plus de temps que
l'Assemblée nationale plus de 1/3 de
temps en plus alors que nous étions
contraints sur 15 jours l'assemblée
était sur 20 jours
je dois dire que si nous l'avons fait
c'est bien pour marquer cette volonté
d'aller jusqu'au bout ce qui nous a
conduit après cinq jours de débat ou
très clairement mais c'est normal
les groupes d'opposition à la réforme se
sont exprimés et la majorité sédatoriale
et au-delà de la majorité les cinq
groupes sur 8 il y a cinq groupes ils ne
sont pas tous par la majorité
sénatoriale souhaite qu'on aille au bout
tout simplement parce qu'il pense que le
rôle d'un parlementaire c'est bien de
voter la loi mais il y a eu des
critiques qui se sont exprimées on va on
va entendre celle de Pascal salvaudéli
c'était en séance le sénateur communiste
du Val-de-Marne
je voulais m'adresser à monsieur le
président Gérard Larcher qu'il m'écoute
monsieur le président Gérard Larcher
dans la nuit d'hier vous avez été
davantage le président des LR que le
président du Sénat en se soumettant en
se soumettant à l'agenda du gouvernement
avec cet article 38 article réclamé par
le président Retailleau et applaudi par
les centristes monsieur le Président
Larcher vous décrébilisez notre
institution et le travail parlementaire
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez est-ce
que l'opposition est-ce que vous
empêcher l'opposition d'examiner cette
loi
exprimé sur le seul article 7 et le
premier amendement de suppression entre
les paroles sur arctique et les
présentations d'amendement 124
interventions je rappelle qu'il y a 348
sénateurs et que les groupes
rassemblés les trois groupes qui
s'opposent ils sont 91 donc
pardonnez-moi des baillons comme ça ça
permet beaucoup de s'exprimer si vous
voulez aller au bout de l'examen est-ce
que vous êtes prêts de nouveau à
utiliser les armes que vous avez à
disposition dans le dans le règlement
l'article 34 c'est prononcer la clôture
quand vous arrivez à 60 prises de parole
je pense que de part et d'autre nous
sommes suffisamment informés des
arguments pour des arguments contre il y
a aussi il y a pas d'autres choix toute
façon si c'est vu le rythme de début de
l'examen faut que vous serez aussi il
faut quand même dire les choses
des sous amendements je vais prendre
hier soir
un sénateur avait prévu de demander un
rapport sur ce que serait l'état de
l'avancement de mise en place de cette
réforme de retraite au 1er janvier 2017
bien nous avions une série de sous
amendements qui portait uniquement sur
la date de remise du rapport est-ce que
janvier 4 janvier et est-ce que c'est
comparable à part nos interrompues
est-ce que c'est comparable à ce qui
s'est passé à l'Assemblée nationale
est-ce que c'est de l'obstruction
Parlement je pense que naturellement
l'idée est trois groupes c'est qu'on
n'aille pas au bout
du débat nous avions j'allais dire eu
que j'appelle en vieux français un
parlement agrémente pour que président
Kanner avait dit souhaité débattre de
l'article 7 le 7 nous avons débattu jour
de l'article 7 le 7 et nous avons voté
l'ensemble de l'article 7 après un très
long débat il y avait eu des moments
consensuels je pense à ce passer
notamment pour les enseignants pour les
professeurs des écoles je pense à ce qui
s'est passé pour les sapeurs-pompiers je
pense ce qui s'est passé pour un certain
nombre de situations liées aux sportifs
nous avons eu même des votes à
l'unanimité sur l'article
47 1 à l'Assemblée article 38 au Sénat
probable 49-3 la semaine prochaine quand
le texte reviendra à l'Assemblée si le
gouvernement estime que la majorité
n'est pas suffisante pour adopter le
texte est-ce que ce serait comme le dit
Laurent Berger un vice démocratique d'en
finir avec un 49-3 d'abord je rappelle
que l'article 38 je vais parler de
règlement du Sénat
il est dans le règlement et il a été
validé par le Conseil constitutionnel et
il y a déjà été utilisé depuis 2015
donc l'article 42 que vous avez un
article qui est lui un article nouveau
lui n'existe que depuis 2015 il s'agit
en quelque sorte d'avoir un temps cadré
pour examiner des articles et
ceci était issu d'ailleurs d'un retour
d'expérience de texte parce que il
s'agit pour un président d'assemblée
j'assume cet article puisque c'est Soum
ma présidence que cet article a été mis
en place le rôle du Parlement c'est
vraiment je le répète
de délibérer et de voter vous ne
répondez pas sur le 49-3 le 49 dans la
Constitution et dans la constitution de
la 5e République et comme celui-ci
il y en a eu d'autres dans la 5e
République c'est même Nicolas Sarkozy
qui a limité
l'utilisation du 49-3 je le rappelle au
seul texte financier c'est le cas de ce
texte puisque c'est un projet de loi de
finance
la sécurité sociale rectificative et qui
la limitait mais ce qu'on entend dans la
session à un seul texte mais ce qu'on
entend dans la déclaration de de
du secrétaire général de la CFDT
c'est une menace voilée c'est à dire que
si le gouvernement utilise le 49-3 à
l'Assemblée le mouvement va continuer
écoutez moi je j'ai un principe je crois
la souveraineté du peuple qui s'exprime
par la médiation de ses représentants je
ne mets pas du tout en cause
l'expression je pense que le droit de
grève
comme le droit d'amendement ils doivent
être absolument défendu et préservé mais
à un moment la légitimité démocratique
et la partie au Parlement d'un point de
vue politique Gérard Larcher on a vu que
le gouvernement avait donc voulu
conclure un accord avec votre famille
politique les républicains pour ce texte
sur les retraites qu'est-ce que cette
réforme change pour votre famille
politique et est-ce qu'on peut voir là
une amorce peut-être d'une alliance plus
large entre le gouvernement et les
républicains je vous disais il y a un
instant que j'étais pour une ligne
indépendante autonome je vous faisais
état de points de différence avec le
gouvernement le Sénat c'est a toujours
été un contre-pouvoir ce n'est pas un
anti-pouvoir nous nous retrouvons sur le
texte retraite mais je reviens des
débats que nous avons eu dans ma famille
politique au moment des primaires nous
pensions tous qu'il était nécessaire
pour préserver le système par
répartition de poser très clairement la
nécessité de
l'ajuster de l'adapter de le moderniser
et la question de l'espérance de la
question d'une alliance politique elle
s'est posée elle se pose même
écoutez quand quelque chose est bon pour
le pays
je vois pas pourquoi nous nous
interdirions
j'allais dire de voter une réforme qui
nous a pas eu bonne pour le pays
d'autant qu'elle s'est inspirée des
travaux du Sénat votre relation avec le
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron on a vu que sous ce quinquennat
depuis 6 mois elle est davantage voilà
favorable cordiale que sous le précédent
quinquennat qu'est-ce qui a changé et
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire voilà pour la
suite moi je pense que notre pays dans
une situation difficile nous étions la
situation financière nous vivons une
guerre en Europe en Ukraine nous avons à
la suite de ces guerres un certain
nombre de difficultés dans le domaine
énergétique dans le domaine financier
nous voyons les Français douter nous
voyons aussi que les Français se sont
détournés
souvent par l'abstention ou par des
votes extrêmes
engagement d'un engagement démocratique
je pense que nous les uns les autres
dans la clarté
prendre nos responsabilités donc être
constructif mais tu as toujours été
qu'est-ce que vous faites
l'attitude qui a été la nôtre
au cours du précédent quinquennat avec
les amendements du scénario voté près de
70% des textes les a amandés
ils a modifiés mais c'est la chance du
bicamérisme on est dans une logique de
l'intérêt du pays et c'est vraiment ma
ligne ma ligne ne conduit donc je vous
repose la question est-ce que les
députés LR sont sur la même ligne
constructives dans l'intérêt du pays
écoutez les collègues et l'air ils ont
été élu dans des conditions difficiles
et ils ne sont pas dans la même
situation j'allais dire politique ils
sont pas dans une majorité et être
député l'air dans une assemblée qui n'a
plus de majorité qui vit quand même une
ambiance qui parfois
m'apparait assez loin des canons d'une
démocratie respectueuse et apaisée ça va
au début de chaque séance de questions
au Gouvernement je rappelle le principe
du respect je crois profondément au
respect mais je pense que nous avons un
dialogue là je vais parler comme membre
des républicains et du groupe les
républicains nous avons un dialogue avec
nos collègues députés nous pouvons avoir
parfois des différences d'approches mais
nous travaillons ensemble alors cette
question finalement de de votre attitude
du côté constructif de la majorité non
mais c'est moi qui le faut que ce soit
non mais attendez parce que je pense
qu'il faut que ça soit positif et
l'intérêt du pays bon c'est ce que je
retiens aussi on va voir comment ça peut
se mettre alors sur deux à l'oeuvre
pardon sur deux autres réformes majeur
qui arrive la loi immigration et puis la
liberté de la femme de mettre fin sa
grossesse j'emploie exactement les mots
utilisés par le président inscrite dans
la Constitution Mathilde est-ce que par
exemple sur le texte sur l'immigration
vous faites confiance à Gérald Darmanin
issu des républicains un ministre de
l'Intérieur pour peut-être reprendre
certaines de vos propositions de la
majorité sénatoriale qui pourrait être à
même de susciter votre votre soutien
votre vote il y a le texte qui nous a
été adressé s'inspire beaucoup à la fois
c'est-à-dire de l'échec de la loi 2018
de la loi colon et nous avions dit à
l'époque quel serait un échec et des
travaux qui ont été conduits par la
commission des lois sur ce dossier se
trouve que le président de la commission
des lois françois-Noël Buffet était
auparavant le rapporteur sur l'ensemble
de la politique migratoire le sujet
c'est est-ce que nous
mettons en place dans notre pays une
politique une politique pour gérer
l'immigration pour gérer les migrations
et cette politique que tu auras aussi
nécessairement une dimension européenne
le texte qui sortira fera le texte du
Sénat
nous sommes en première lecture nous
avons donc une responsabilité
particulière mais nous devons répondre à
un certain nombre de questions vous ne
dites pas que vous ne que le groupe LR
ne votera pas ce texte vous savez tout
le texte du Sénat et de la majorité
c'est notoriale ce sera la majorité de
déterminer son choix des sujets aussi
importants que l'asile que le
regroupement familial a traité nous
avons le sujet des étudiants nous avons
sur les contrats de travail métiers en
tension vous y êtes opposé jusqu'à
présent pourquoi je pense que il faut
que nous regardions ce sujet de près
pour éviter d'en faire une forme d'appel
nous avons des sujets sur les
prestations sociales que nous devons
gérer en fait la politique migratoire
c'est un des grands échecs
du quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron les
chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes nous ne
maîtrisons plus du tout les phénomènes
migratoires et d'ailleurs nous ne
maîtrisons tellement peu qu'on ne
s'étonne même plus des drames qui ont
lieu chaque semaine dans la Manche ou
chaque semaine dans la Méditerranée moi
je dois vous dire que ma conception des
valeurs humaines c'est de dire il faut
une politique migratoire et cette
politique migratoire elle ne peut pas se
terminer pour un certain nombre d'hommes
et de femmes au fond de la Manche je
trouve ça insupportable il nous reste à
les deux minutes dernier thème sur
l'inscription de de l'IVG dans la
Constitution vous avez entendu le
président de la République hier qui
s'est exprimé et qui a dit donc vouloir
reprendre cette proposition dans un
projet de loi constitutionnel plus large
et qui requiert bien sûr les 3/5 une
majorité des 3/5 du Parlement est-ce que
ça vous semble pertinent dans passer par
un projet d'ensemble est-ce que vous
êtes prêts encore une fois elle lui
accorder votre soutien moi je suis
depuis très très longtemps
je peux me permettre de le dire un
militant de l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse et je dois dire que parmi mes
préoccupations il y a les conditions
d'accès les femmes
ce qu'on appelle une liberté mais ce qui
parfois est j'allais dire une contrainte
aussi et avoir vu 130
fermez en disant ça c'est une vraie
préoccupation avoir vu l'esprit de la
loi veille notamment sur l'entretien
préalable pour ces jeunes femmes puis
j'allais dire la suite
j'allais dire de la technique
chirurgicale qui correspond à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
quand elle n'est pas dans une forme
médicale est-ce qu'on respecte la loi
Veil mon premier sujet c'est de
respecter la loi veille si madre disait
qu'elle n'était pas favorable à ce que
les sujets sociétaux soient inscrits
comme une forme de catalogue dans la
Constitution c'est ma position
aujourd'hui je n'y suis pas favorable
mais il y a eu un débat au Sénat je suis
président d'une assemblée et qui
respecte aussi les votes qui ont eu lieu
au Sedat sur une proposition
de l'ancien président de la commission
des lois Philippe Bas membre des
républicains il y a eu une proposition
sur la
é une formulation qui a repris Emmanuel
Macron mais oui j'ai bien noté et pas du
tout la formule que madame panot avait
utilisé on est aux antipodes en fait le
Sénat quelque part et dans sa vocation
d'être attentif au respect des libertés
individuelles et collectives mais
personnellement je continue à penser et
que
la Constitution n'est pas le lieu de
l'inscription de liste des sujets
sociétaux parce que nous aurons d'autres
sujets qui vont venir la fin de vie
de constitution pardon là il s'agit de
mettre l'IVG avec d'autres sujets sur
les régions possiblement la
décentralisation les modes de scrutin
comme d'habitude au Sénat liberté de
vote vote en conscience en suivant merci
serait vigilant merci beaucoup Gérard si
vous retourné dans l'hémicycle là tout
de suite donc pas tout de suite je vais
aller
dans rien vous cacher
de nos anciennes collègues socialistes
reçoivent la Légion d'honneur et je vais
y aller pour rendre hommage à l'action
qu'elle a eu ici au Sénat merci beaucoup
Gérard lâcher à bientôt dans cette
émission